J&J has emerged as the leader in the
race for an Ebola vaccine the company
says it will have 250,000 dosages of an
experimental vaccine by May and a
million by the end of next year while
glaxosmithkline is still working out how
to produce enough of its medicine
already being tested we want to look at
this strategy j and J's strategy now
that's chief scientific officer Paul
stifles and our ace healthcare reporter
Shannon petty piece joining us as well
you know what I find so interesting Paul
and I'll dress this to you is although
there are a lot of skeptics obviously on
Wall Street it seems like a straight-up
altruistic move like J&J is looking at
this investing two hundred million
dollars working with people who are
normally competitors in order to be good
world citizens is that the case well the
case is uh is is an important one Ebola
is a global epidemic where it's out of
control and we were asked by the world
community Twitter whr dr. Margaret Chan
to provide the response to that as an
industry having vaccines and so that we
were asked to significantly accelerate
because the disease is out of control
and since we have the capability the
capacity we have the signs of Technology
in the capacity to produce we we are
gearing up the max we can to make as
many vaccines as possible as soon as
possible to help to the world to protect
against Ebola and Paul will you make a
profit on this is this something J&J can
make money off eventually it's
absolutely not the first objective here
we don't know we are working hard to in
response to a global crisis and
afterwards we'll see if the vaccine
becomes a global globally use vaccine
one day maybe we'll see how it goes on
but the first thing now is being as fast
as possible to help the world get in
control of this disease as as the first
and foremost objective Paul described
for us where the development is right
now as I understand that J&J plans to
have these doses ready by May but what
needs to happen between now and may well
do we know today we have done the
testing of the prime boost
at the NIH labs I've shown one hundred
percent protection if you use two
different vaccines which is called a
heterologous prime boost and by
combining the adrenal 26 factor
including Ebola we have combined to the
mva vector from bavarian nordic we have
been able to show in preclinical models
100% protection what we also know is
that in test batches we have been doing
in the last few weeks we have been able
to significantly upscale and we were
able to produce 140,000 vaccines in a 10
liter vessel which is now used to do the
preclinical toxicity the pharmaceutical
formulation everything which is needed
to bring it up to the next round of GMP
production what we also know is that the
variant Nordics can follow with that
production in parallel with us what we
now have to do is do first safety trials
in patients which will start early
January as early as possible in January
and that will take us two to three
months to learn whether the vaccine is
well tolerated and gives immunogenicity
it gives protection which we can measure
in humans but by taking blood if we know
that we are ready to start large-scale
phase 3 2 3 studies in may as well as
will have 250,000 vaccine combinations
available to be deployed in in the world
to protect health care workers and
people at risk living with family with
everyone Paul I mean this all sounds
great but there's a lot of risks around
vaccine production and you're moving at
an unprecedented rate we've never seen
someone try and produce a vaccine this
quickly under this type of circumstances
what are the risks what are the costs
cautionary things that people should be
thinking about here yeah the risk of
course is that we still need to test it
in humans for safety and that will know
in the first three months of next year
but besides that we know cat that we can
make it we know that it's effective in
animals and so the risk is now the next
step on safety and immunogenicity if
that works out I'm pretty confident that
we'll be able in the course of next year
to deliver a vaccine which hopefully can
help people to protect we also know that
we can scale up to at least 1 million in
the core
of next year about 250,000 per quarter
and we are working with industry
partners across the world to even go
further if we find the right capacity
capabilities to do that yeah talk to me
about that collaboration because you're
working with other companies over in
Europe but you're considering the
possibility if glaxosmithkline for
example gets on the right track to pool
resources and work with even these big
competitors what's that collaborate
collaboration like because it doesn't
seem like something you see very often
well we have seen an unprecedented reach
out within the pharmaceutical industry
between the senior executives on helping
each other and that includes not just
glaxosmithkline it also includes Pfizer
and other companies who are bringing
their their production capabilities to
bear we are discussing that as we speak
in order to accelerate even more than we
can today so you're meeting with
capacity your meeting with your talking
to the chief scientific officers at
these other companies yes and Alex is
talking to all the CEOs of these
companies so we'll make sure that
everyone is working together here to get
to the best possible results Paul one
thing I wonder given the resources and
time and effort the J&J is pouring into
the search for in a bowl of vaccine what
do you have to back burner as a result
nothing I mean I think the engagement
you get in your organization is
fantastic to do this everyone will put
in the extra hours on top of what we do
for the rest of the business today so
there is going to be no impact on any
other other programs our team is very
very very very dedicated very encouraged
to do that and everyone in J&J the
125,000 employees all or committing part
of their time on top of what they do
normally for for the company so I
wouldn't worry about that now you're
looking for a vaccine which would help
to protect hundreds of thousands and
potentially millions of people from
contracting Ebola in the future is there
anything you're learning in that
development process that could be
applied to the
work being done right now on Ebola
treatments well it I should highlight
that the vaccine of course is to protect
people who are not yet infected right
and and that is and that will take time
to do to deploy etc of course we have
capabilities in other areas and also
there the industry is pulling together
across all of the pharmaceutical group
companies to learn how we can quickly do
what we do with vaccines now bring to
bear for drugs and we are also part of
that and more news to follow in the
coming months about that because you
will see an unprecedented effort in
industry also to get this done but then
for therapy Paul should have this
collaboration been happening sooner now
I mean now run a trajectory where we
could have 10,000 people a week infected
by December is this why isn't this
happening sooner it is what it is and we
reworked we worked under the radar for
already very very hard four months this
is not that we started yesterday what we
learned in the last few weeks why we are
confident now to talk about is that we
were able to upscale the production
because we have the purses six align
which is a very unique cell line which
can have huge yields in very small
volumes it helps us to go and accelerate
that and that's we are the confirmation
that we can do this now that we have the
confirmation I'm very confident to talk
to the world to say we are committed to
do this in the shortest possible time
now that all of the technical elements
have been validated but has reassured
that this is not started yesterday this
started already months ago when we knew
that Ebola was going to be a problem in
the world